[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 1st of
December I'm Kate Andrews the
spectator's economics editor and your
host this week coming up on the show
have museums turned on their own
collections a collection at the welcome
trust has closed down for being quote
racist sexist and ableist the latest
symbol Douglas Murray says of a wider
cultural panic and Retreat what could
this mean for the future of arts and
culture Douglas and Lord Ed fasey will
be on the show to discuss and debate
how many moratory MPS will choose not to
stand in the next election and are we
looking ahead to a festive season of
strikes James Forsyth and Katie balls
join me for your politics update
as the NHS buckles under Rising waiting
lists could there be a helpful fix Lucy
Dunn The Spectator social media editor
and a qualified doctor thinks we should
free the pharmacy and give more power to
pharmacists to prescribe medicine we'll
hear what she has to say
if Donald Trump announcing his
presidential bid wasn't enough for you
America has gone one step further yea
formerly known as Kanye West has thrown
his hat into the ring and is doubling
down on anti-semitic comments in this
week's magazine Freddie gray looks at
whether there is any chance of yay
splitting the right-wing vote he joins
me with Amber Athie who had a strange
encounter with yay recently in a
recording studio
and finally I'm sure many of you will
remember Lolo
I shall say this only once
last night listen I shall say this only
one Neil Clark has written a love letter
to the show 40 years later about what we
can glean from humor in difficult times
all that to come but before we get going
if you enjoy spectator TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon to
make sure you never miss an episode
first up Douglas Murray has written the
cover piece for the magazine this week
as museums are faced with mounting
pressure to reframe the history behind
their collections how far will they go
to cover up the past he joins me now
with Lord Ed vasey former culture
minister
it's for the cover piece this week you
have written about the culture wars
infiltrating museums what's been
happening
well I start off with a description of
going to the Pitt Rivers Museum in
Oxford this past week the Pitt Rivers
museum has always been an interesting
Oddity of a museum a collection of of
mainly 19th century collected artifacts
it's
um it was a place famed among other
things for the Pickled heads that it had
in it and even as an undergraduate more
than 20 years ago now it was it was it
was known of us being an oddity but an
oddity from another time
um and I discovered on returning this
week that it's now become an oddity of
our own time
uh the museum is filled with
condemnations of the museum The
Collection is filled with condemnations
of the collection almost everything
tells you about the sins of European
colonialism European racism there are of
course all of the nods to the religion
of our time there are segments on beyond
the binary because I'm sure that's what
everybody wants when they go to the pit
Rivers collection and we see for
instance anime characters from the 1990s
feel a strong queer icons my point is
that the museum is effectively
abolishing itself it's saying that the
collection was put together by bad
forces and it has to be saved in the
modern era reinterpreted and indeed
accused now this as I say in my cover
piece this week is not at all unusual it
is something that is going on the
collection after collection of Museum
and Museum after museum across the land
and the Oddity of this is not just that
this is in fact encouraged by for
instance the Museum's Association which
which tells collections in your are in
in the UK how to quote decolonize but of
course that the collections themselves
are doing it we just saw last weekend
the welcome collection of London's
Houston Road announcing that it was
closing its exhibition why because it
had tried to decolonize but it couldn't
tear itself away from its dead white
male Origins and so the welcome
collection announced that it would be
closing it couldn't justify itself so in
the end it stopped
Ed you've read Douglas's piece what did
she make into his Deep dive of what's
happening in museums and the collections
that are present there
well I've got a huge problem uh with
Douglas's piece which is that I agreed
with quite a lot of it so it's going to
be quite hard to have an argument I
think if one unpacks it I mean Douglas
has used
some pretty forceful examples to make
his point as you would expect from uh
one of the country's most successful
columnists and I being a sort of bland
neutral slightly flabby figure uh sit
somewhere in the Midland this which is
that I get engaged in the culture wars
because I think to a certain extent both
sides take rather extreme positions I
think that it is in the 21st century
perfectly possible to look at a museum
collection uh that was a crude say in
the 19th uh Century or the 18th century
and say how did this Museum come by
these objects were they
taken fairly purchased in good faith and
transported back to the UK or were they
looted by British soldiers and if they
were is that something that we should
consider when we put these things on
display and one of the reasons I get
asked onto programs like this is because
I'm in favor of returning the Parthenon
sculptures the default position which to
a certain extent to coin a phrase every
Schoolboy learns is that Lord Elgin
saved the Parthenon sculptures and they
would have been blown up by these
feckless uh or been allowed to be blown
up by these factors Greeks if Lord Elgin
hadn't intervened I don't think that's
an accurate depiction at all about how
the Parthenon sculptures came to be in
London and even if it was I think now in
the 21st century a perfectly reasonable
request from the Greek government to
potentially have them back should be
considered
um in a sensible way but I do think as
well and this is where Douglas May well
disagree with me so we'll get some juice
out of this uh that it is worth thinking
about cultural seven sensitivities in
the 21st century I mean he cites the Rex
Whistler mural at Tate now I wasn't a
trustee of tape when the trustees made
the decision to close the restaurant
because the images of uh in the mural
were deemed to be offensive but I
respect their decision it wasn't taken
lightly it was thoroughly uh examined
and I'm afraid it is the case that in
the 21st century a lot of people
wandering into the restaurant and seeing
Rex whistler's mural regardless of the
context would find those figures
offensive and it was on the table to
have an explainer or whatever about why
those Figures were there but it was
considered very carefully and I I
support that this is the key point I
support trustees looking at these issues
and making decisions on that basis but
he I fully concede to a certain extent
and indeed I have trolled my own museum
Tate sometimes the labels go completely
over the top and are bordering on the
ridiculous
um let me just if I may pick up on two
things there first of all what I'm
writing about is a different issue than
dxession de-accession is its own issue
at the moment I think we would disagree
on the argument marbles but de-accession
of course has already led to its own
types of lunacy such as for instance the
belief that all bronzes from Benin must
be handed back this came to the extent
that uh two a couple of years ago after
the summer of George Floyd Lambeth
Palace got rid of tubing in bronzes
handed them back to Benin when in fact
these bronzes were gifts to Ronald
runtsy the Archbishop of Canterbury who
as it happened uh christened me as a boy
um they were giving him the 1980s and he
handed them back as if his successors
rather Lambeth Palace handed them back a
couple of years ago as if they were
holding on to a set of stolen Hot
televisions secondly what uh Ed vasey
mentions about uh I'm glad he says that
I use strong examples in my piece and
I'm sure he'd expect that there's no
point in writing and using weak examples
but the example of Tate Britain
um I think with all due respect it is
entirely wrong about the Tate trustees
took action with extraordinary levity
the trustees of the Tate are ignoramuses
to a man and a woman
every single one of them and let me
explain briefly why the Rex Whistler
mural was commissioned in the 1920s it
includes two tiny figures of black
children clearly in distress being
pulled by women in frilly frocks
laughing it's clearly as any scholar or
fan of Rex Whistler knows something he
does in all of his murals which is to
say it in Arcadia ego this is a a
Fantastical idyllic scene in which he
deliberately across all four walls puts
in tiny details to say even in this
alleged Paradise the worm of human evil
exists the trustees of the Tate did not
consider this who they listened to were
two activists on Instagram from a group
called White pube white pubes the slogan
is F the police F the UK F the Tate now
I don't need to tell Lord vasey F the
Tate is not a chance you often hear on
the streets of London most people don't
have that strong views on Tate Britain
this was a malevolent tiny group of
activists who decided to defame Rex
Whistler the trustees of the Tate far
from looking into this immediately got
scared they closed the room they took
Rex whistler's name off it they defamed
him first of all as a racist and then
put up a sign saying that he had the
racist views of his time why do I mind
this not just because the Tate is meant
to house and look after one of our great
collections but because Rex Whistler
died childless fighting on his first day
in Normandy in 1944 how dare one of the
great collections of the UK be in the
hands of people who would defame as a
racist somebody who joined up on the
first weeks of the war in 1939 and laid
down his life fighting Nazism these
people are not looking at these things
carefully any more than they have the
example of Stanley Spencer who they've
also decided to defend in their
collection as a racist these collections
are in the hands of people who are
Unworthy of the things in their care Ed
I think that is I think now Douglas has
slightly descended into caricature I
mean I wasn't a trustee of take when
this decision uh was made but the idea
that uh Tate would make a decision to
close this restaurant uh and uh remove
the mural which they haven't done by the
way uh
somebody had put up an Instagram two
activists to put up an Instagram post uh
is absolutely laughable and I see
nothing wrong with museums first of all
thinking hard about how a collection is
viewed by an audience in the 21st
century as opposed to an audience that
visits uh in the 19th century and that
could include uh the shrunken heads at
the pit Rivers Museum and I think it's
perfectly uh in order for museums to put
in context how objects were acquired by
that collection and in fact the context
of the time in which they were acquired
so I see uh absolutely no problem uh
with that at all and I think so I think
that it's it's uh the idea that you
wouldn't modernize your displays and
your collections and put them in context
in the 21st century I think is uh
laughable the idea is that our Museum
should kind of sit in aspic and be
exactly as our Victorian forefathers uh
visited them before uh seems to me
laughable I'd like to ask you each a
question to challenge your perspectives
um and Douglas to you first this point
about context is important isn't it
um putting aside some of the more
extreme examples where they've just
decided to shut down collections would
you have an issue with curators deciding
that rather than shutting things down
they would like to give a modern context
and they would like to give more
information to those visiting the museum
I mean presumably that is their remit of
course so that people really understand
what they're consuming and perhaps some
of the atrocities behind what they're
consuming
oh yes absolutely by the way Ed Rosie
sets up as a tall man as politicians of
his kind always do not nothing you would
ever do Douglas no I don't need to
believe me I don't need to
um he sets up a straw man by pretending
that I or anyone like me thinks that we
should preserve our Collections and
aspic I don't believe that at all I
think that trustees obviously always
have to reinvigorate and renew
collections what I think is strange is
that they should hate the collections
which they are in charge of again I come
back to the point I followed unlike Ed
extremely closely the activities that
they take in recent years and also
observed extremely closely the way in
which they decided to make Stanley
Spencer one of the other two great
artists of the 20th century in their
collection into a posthumous racist for
no good reason at all so yes that's what
I find strange but to get back to your
point Kate the interesting thing about
this were retain and explain thing is
it's absolutely fine and admirable so
long as it isn't a one directional
political hit job and let me give you an
example of what a one-directional
political hit job looks like if you want
to for instance say parts of this museum
were put together by in an era of
colonialism in Europe or colonialism in
Britain fine who doesn't mind that I
don't mind that I don't think anyone
would mind that but here's what I mind
is when you for instance as at the pit
Rivers get that and then a strange
silence on everywhere else in the world
for instance the kingdom of Benin which
has already come up a couple of times if
you stand before the display on the
kingdom of Benin in the pit Rivers
Museum in Oxford do you learn anything
about slavery curiously enough no do you
learn that the kingdom of Benin was
practicing slavery long after the
British Empire decided to abolish it and
sent its ships across the seas trying to
stamp it out anywhere else no and you
would leave believing that the rest of
the planet lived in Eden until the
wicked Europeans arrive it's not
education it's self-flagellation
I think that uh without wishing to
descend into cliche two wrongs uh don't
make uh a right and um it is up to us to
put into context the collections that we
have in this country and how they were
Acquired and 99 of them were required uh
perfectly uh legitimately and it's a
great thing as well that we have these
British institutions that display uh an
extraordinary range of artifacts and
paintings from all over uh the world but
I think when the Benin bronzes were
looted uh that we should own up to that
fact and think about returning them but
Ed some of the Benin bronzes were given
to this country by the prime minister of
Nigeria after Independence what do we do
with those
uh well I mean I'm not gonna I don't
know enough about Robert Francis
you haven't thought about it enough but
if he uh if uh if they require
legitimately you know it's a matter of a
Lambert Palace if they were if they're
their possessions what they what they
wish to uh what they wish to do with
them and I have two contributions for
you Ed first is
um do we not Risk by removing so-called
offensive artwork
um losing parts of History losing those
uncomfortable offensive parts of History
uh do we not risk
suggesting that these things never
happened at all and actually to a more
fundamental point about offense as well
since when is it wrong for art or great
works of literature to be offensive to
challenge us for us to be uncomfortable
with what we see if we decide that such
works are too risky for people to be
exposed to what are we going to be
looking at when we go into museums
what's going to be there to challenge us
I think it's a very fair Challenge and I
think it's a very nuanced debate and to
a certain extent you should do it um
object by object I think as I say I
wasn't a trustee when uh the Tate
trustee is considered the Rex Whistler
mural but they clearly took the view
that these were effectively racial
caricatures and no uh attempt to put
them in uh context or whatever would
necessarily reduce the offense that a
modern 21st century audience whether
it's black or white would feel when they
were coming in to have a nice lunch at
Tate so they've taken that decision and
I think you know what I want to get
across there I think Douglas is to be
frank being very very unfair to think
that this was a sort of decision taken
uh you know in a nanosecond um I'm being
wired over a couple of um digestive
biscuits and a cup of tea I think it was
thought through very carefully over very
can I ask Ed what he thinks about the
Stanley Spence I think the trustees can
I ask Ed what he thinks
as far as I'm aware Stanley Spencer is
still on full display at Dave Britain
and it's not called a racist in by Tate
or anyone else I can assure you can this
is very important with a former Arts
Minister because you have to be on top
of these things I'm sorry but as with
the Benin brontes you have to be on top
of this
to Nigeria Nigeria hasn't thrown off his
hands in horror and said you shouldn't
return these you've got them perfectly
legitimately and I'm on top of Stanley
Spencer in the sense and I say Stanley
Spencer remains on full display at Tate
and it's not called a racist
yes he is
go down there today if you have the time
and you will see that his Masterpiece
the resurrection at cookham in in the
accompanying description as I say in my
piece claims that Stanley Spencer used
racialized images of black people now it
doesn't bother to say that in this
extraordinary Masterpiece as I'm sure
you'll agree it is if you know the
painting in this extraordinary
Masterpiece that displays the the
resurrection of the Dead on the day of
judgment in Stanley Spencer's Church
nearby churchyard in cookham it shows
people of all Races emerging from the
grace
uh you know calling somebody a racist
that is not calling him a racist go back
to the quote I give him the piece as
with Rex Whistler they look at the work
in their in their truck in their care
with the most hostile lens imaginable
there was nobody black in cookham in the
1920s
please let me finish finish your point
Ed response I'm going to ask one more
question and then we're going to wrap up
because we're well over time Douglas you
have 30 seconds
a reasonable estimation of the Spencer
painting in the Tate is that because
there was nobody black and cook them at
the time if you wanted to show the
resurrection of all of humanity yes he
relied on photographs from National
Geographic does that make him a racist
obviously not is it what he has impuned
as being by Tate yes it's right by the
painter I don't agree that's the case at
all
we'll go down and see it to Ed and
Douglas uh add to you first do you think
that the way in which museums are now
curated and the way that art is
presented to us has become too
politicized or do you think that the
interventions that are taking place now
are crucial to a modern understanding of
what happened in the past
well I started this uh debate by saying
that I agreed with a lot of uh what
Douglas wrote in his article as I say I
think that extreme positions are taken
on uh both sides and I think that on one
side questioning or uh referring to the
fact that you know some objects were
acquired in by dubious means Were
Somehow being unpatriotic and unbritish
or as Douglas is uh in terms of working
himself up just now you know that we're
going around calling Stanley Spencer a
racist I think is ludicrous but at the
same time I do accept that there are
plenty of examples in our museums at the
moment uh where people have taken it to
the other extreme and there are kind of
gratuitous labels and narratives that
don't really fit you know I am quite
woke on these issues I mean I see
nothing wrong for example in terms of
gcses and a levels in extending uh the
English literature curriculum towards
world uh literature I don't see anything
wrong with those kind of things and
people foam at the mouth if you dare to
suggest that children in British schools
might study authors who weren't born and
bred in Britain and wrote from outside
so I see nothing wrong with looking at
our curriculum looking at our at the
objects in museums putting them in
context and extending the range
of objects that people see and uh
re-imagining the narrative Douglas who
wanted politics feature in museum
curation and to what extent is it
inevitable I mean ultimately the people
making these decisions will come with
not a neutral point of view and and
you're always going to have some lens
put on what is presented to you
um the job of Trustees of a collection
is to ensure the continuation of the
collection is to know that it is in your
hands for your generation to pass on to
the next one I say in the piece how
extraordinary it is that so much of what
I described has gone on under a
conservative government and I think Lord
vasey has just demonstrated why and how
it is please call me in but but as I say
I think that essentially what we have is
the National Heritage is to a great
extent in the hands of people who don't
much care for it even in one famous
essay and spectator reviewing Stephen
spender's Memoir said that that reading
Stephen Spender in mangling the English
language was like watching a very
valuable vars in the hands of a
chimpanzee
um watching our national Collections and
their trustees and curators at the
moment is like seeing all the most
precious things in our culture in the
hands of chimpanzees they are utterly
for the task they had been appointed to
Adam Douglas thanks for joining me
who would want to be an MP that's the
question MPS themselves are asking us
the deadline for standing in the next
general election approaches the
spectator's political editor James
Forsyth and Deputy political editor
Katie balls join me now
Katie James thanks for joining spectator
TV James and you're calling for the
magazine this week you write about the
early retirement really early retirement
of some Tory MPS talk us through it yeah
I'm starting one of the Striking things
about the tour retirements which are not
at the moment that numerous ahead of
Monday's deadline is how young some of
them are you know the Tory retirements
are on on average 20 years younger than
the equivalent labor MPS retiring uh I
think that's Chloe Smith who won her
seat in the bar action in 2009 she's was
the 27 when she was first elected
youngest MP in the Commons at the time
but then you look at all the things that
have happened in our life since you know
she's fought that seat five times uh
she's had kids as an MP she's battled
breast cancer you can see why she's had
enough then there's to Hannah Davidson
who was one of the kind of signature
Tory gains in 2019 she won that seat
when she was very young and the starting
thing about her decision to stand down
is that she is currently a minister
before her 30th birthday normally you
think that anyone who was on that track
wouldn't go but she and standing down
said that you know she felt that being
in politics so much in her 20s when she
hadn't had a kind of normal 20-something
experience
um and so I think the the the the the
the these MPS stepping down I think well
I think oh it will make parties think a
little bit about how young some people
are when they get elected but I also
think they represent a slight shift
which it used to be that people did
things and then did politics now I think
people are doing politics and then going
off to do something else I mean struck
by some MPS who uh
have retired you know the episode that
you know if they go now they'll have
something time to do another career
properly rather than just a at the end
of uh their working line so I think I
mean there is a slight shift in and I
suppose it comes out of a kind of
Greater professionalization of politics
you know which is more people
um you know working from party activists
to party advisor to then running for a
seat
I think number 10 is taking the news of
these uh early retirements do you think
they look at it as individual cases or
do you think they're getting a little
bit worried that perhaps these MPS don't
think they have a chance of winning in
the next election so I think there's
some concern about the Optics of having
lots of young MPS say actually I don't
see a future with the conservative party
as you know a member of parliament which
to your point uh you say well that's
because you think you're going to lose
the city at the next election the vast
majority when it comes to the Fairly the
relatively younger MPS who are making
this decision do you have 30 small
majorities and obviously labor are far
ahead in the polls so it doesn't look
good even with 18 months to go to the
next election
I think you have to be a little bit
careful though of um almost over reading
into you know this Mass departure which
yes could be happening but if you look
at the list that I'll call you James
heals you know updating on coffee house
there's not actually a huge difference
right now between the number of Labor
MPS and the number of Tory MPS stepping
down there is a difference in age I
would say on some of these younger MPS
so even Deanna Davison they're all quite
independently minded MPS Deanna Davison
yes was the post to go in many ways in
the 2019 election
um with the bishop Auckland seat but
she's also someone who's rebelled
several times before becoming a minister
and I I seen to have her own brand on
social media and therefore it's uh
probably a different sense of perhaps
what they're doing in terms of their
plans for politics and government then
perhaps some of the the MPS who come
more through the traditional spad route
um and I I think of these bad 10 MPS
will start resigning or saying they're
not going to stand for their elections
that's a big sign that I think the
traditional route um and we can query
the traditional route you know there is
something going wrong which means these
super competitive MPS don't don't see a
don't see a point in continuing so we
know there's a deadline of the fifth of
December to say if you don't plan to
stand for re-election in a way it's a
little bit of a fake deadline and
there's nothing stopping an MP from
deciding much nearer the time and
speaking to some MPS red wall MPS are on
the fence at the moment about what their
plans will be you've also got the
boundary review which means some seats
you know being divided and moved
actually not saying well why would I say
I'm gonna leave now because then I'm
just a lame duck MP and I've got much
more power in terms of what I want to do
in Parliament if I just hang on and if I
decide you know in a year's time that
actually things aren't looking up for
the party that's when I can make my move
so I think this is going to be a gradual
picture in terms of getting a full sense
of how much of an exodus this is and
just other than to take into account is
this is going to be the first you know
the election the past two elections will
snap elections now often MPS plan around
this you know I'll do my four or five
year term and then I'll make my plans
and therefore you could have a higher
number purely because this is almost
going back to the conventional election
cycle as opposed to having these snap
elections sprung on you due to big
events which we haven't been used to for
quite a few years now uh James to
Katie's point about this almost fake
deadline
um there is still a while presumably
until the next election unless something
crazy happens and as we've learned from
the past few months things can change
rather rapidly so um to her point you
know perhaps the people who are
announcing early retirement now really
aren't the best indicator of how Tory
MPS in particular are actually feeling
about their their prospects in the next
election yeah and I think it would be a
big surprise if the next election was
much before kind of you know um
certainly 2024 but and I suspect
probably relatively late in 2024 too
um I I think that you know I think a lot
of story MPS are just waiting to see
what happens you know I mean you know do
the poll numbers improve you know where
is the economy this time next year I
think there's a big question you know
how fast has inflation Fallen you know
is if inflation is back down at three or
four percent rather than the 11 it's at
now this time next year then I think
that you know people will begin to feel
very different I think it is inflation
which is making politics so scratchy at
the moment and Katie this week the Prime
Minister Rishi sinach made one of his
first big interventions about China this
was a turned out to be a key part of the
leadership debate especially because the
foreign prime minister Liz truss was
really pushing Rishi neck on this topic
what did we learn from what he said this
week
so this was the first big speech did you
say which setting up foreign policy
vision and this area where we know you
know the least about Richard scenic's
views and given his Thomas chance there
was mainly domestic
um and he talked about taking a tough
stance on China but he also talked about
you know robust pragmatism which I think
um runs some alarm Bells amongst you
know members of the China research
groups the China Hawks and the party
what is this pragmatism is that a
softening I think from the speech we
actually learned that not that much has
changed right now and but the real uh
fight so to speak is about how you
define China is it a systemic challenge
which is what was in the integrated
review is it systemic threat and that's
what uh Tori MPS like Ian Duncan Smith
want to see and we've seen calls for the
prime minister's questions and MP's
saying actually we shouldn't call it a
threat and remember she said it
confirmed in his speech there will be an
update to the integrated review which
sets out all these things in the new
year I think there is a change that's
where the change will be so I think we
saw from the speech
some questions being raised uh about uh
Rishi cnx approach and if he is going to
take a softer approach then there's
Trust on China and given she talked
about making it a threat but didn't
actually get around to doing it
um but I think this is really a battle
for the New Year where we'll probably
see fully where he is I think it's also
just worth remembering that inside
government there is a sense that you
know Boris Johnson really went on a
journey so to speak
um during his time as prime minister
where he hardened his position on China
he's into Huawei and a lot of this is
also not just Tory MPS what the US is
doing and and I think there is a similar
sense that uh the various figures in
government I want to take Rishi sunak on
a journey and before any decisions are
made though you can see in a few of the
um you know investment decisions the
government have taken to block or you
know sell off China Chinese involvement
they're they're already actions even if
Rishi sunak is more of the type who
doesn't want to you know come up really
bold statements there is some action
suggest that you he's not being you know
you know it's not a complete change of
softening
James
um all Western countries are in a tricky
spot when it comes to China right now
it's zero covert policy
um is having a direct impact on the
Chinese economy but it's certainly
having an indirect impact on the
recovery is happening around the world
uh in addition to that the decoupling
process has certainly been sped up by
not just covet but by the warn in
Ukraine as well because of the way that
the world has quite rightly reacted to
Russia that's been assigned to China
that you know we're only going to get
tougher on this stuff we're not going to
get easier when it comes to your abuse
of Human Rights
um this is a it's a tricky spot for any
prime minister or leader at a time where
the economy is not looking so great you
want to get normal Supply chains back on
track but at the same time you must
these days show very clear opposition to
what's happening the russia-china way so
I think the big one of the big
challenges for uh Democratic societies
over the next few decades is to reduce
their dependence on authoritarian
regimes I think we've seen uh the
problems that have been caused for those
European countries that are particularly
dependent on Russian gas by the invasion
of Ukraine and the knock-on effects for
the broader European energy Market I I
think what you need here I mean one of
the big questions is you know
undoubtedly the entry of China into the
world economy was a kind of deflationary
shock I mean one of the reasons why the
nice decade was so nice was because
China had had entered into the world
economy it came online
um yeah I think I think I think the
challenge is how do you manage to reduce
your dependence on China without kind of
going back to kind of protectionism and
everything must be very domestically
based Supply chains and I think the
friend Shoring there is the answer you
know that is that is like-minded
countries coming together to uh to build
Supply chains that allow National
comparative advantage but don't leave
you dependent on an unpredictable
authoritarian regime and Katie it's
December 1st for a lot of people out
there they'll be counting down to
Christmas but in Westminster it seems to
be that we're looking on to 25 days
worth of strikes how is the government
going to manage repeated strikes across
different sectors in what is supposed to
be a festive season and when a lot of
people are going to be
at the best in convenience and at the
worst put in a really tough spot I'm
thinking about the nurses strike in
patients who need to go into Hospital
yeah I mean I think there's multiple
problems that has been said many times
you know this is a winter of discontent
in these ways and Strikes transport the
NHS and the ambulance strikes which can
now happen on top of this and I think
those are the problems are twofold and
the one is well how do these Services
continue the NHS is already under severe
strain so what impact is this going to
have and then also of course the
political ramifications which is do
people blame the government
um and does the government blink and
then have to offer you know much more
generous pay packages to these public
sector workers I thought what's
interesting at Prime Minister's
questions that Richard Cena when the
nurses strike demands came up which is
probably the most emotive and
politically tricky you think about the
level of support for nurses particularly
during covert you know people going out
to clap that he said actually the demand
that they had in terms of that that
amount was unreasonable and unaffordable
and so unreasonable is something where
you know lots of people say well it is
you can see you already had labor of
trying to weaponize that but I think
with Russia Scenic there is something
where lots of people think because he
has more softly spoken than I think both
Boris Johnson and Liz truss who will do
you know more Grand rhetoric on these
issues
um people can think that also means
perhaps a softer approach but I but I I
do get the sense the government is going
to be very reluctant and as the
government does blink on one of these
and obviously it all starts to become
much harder so I I think that they are
gearing up to actually pretty be pretty
Steely
um I think one I think one of the things
is just how expensive it would be to to
raise public sector pay in line of
inflation it's 18 billion pounds that
that's the equivalent of free p on the
basic rate of income tax and I mean you
know one of the things is that you know
it's impossible to say just borrow that
money now in the current circumstances
and so you're looking at either putting
up taxes yet again all cutting services
and you know neither of those are
palatable options right now I think that
you know I think in political terms as
Katie said this relatively tough
approach might be I mean it's not
particularly palatable but it might be
the least unpalatable of the options
available and of course private sector
pay is going up but it's not going up by
the rate of inflation on average James
Katie made the very interesting point
there about who the public are going to
blame in this festive season of strikes
and I'm really curious about this one
because I wonder what threshold is
amongst the public for putting up with
these inconveniences when we have had
two plus years really going on three
years now of mass inconvenience
are leaving the public will punish
anyone who looks like they're enjoying
the confrontation I mean the key battle
is to appear to be the reasonable party
in this
um and I think that perhaps explains why
Mark Harper the transport section has
been prepared to meet Lynch with the rmt
why Steve Barkley the health secretary
keeps always emphasizing that you know
one 19 is unaffordable you know his door
is always open to the nurses if they
want to talk and so I think I think
reasonableness is the key test although
I think one worry for government will be
but the longer strikes go on the more
the public tend to think just sort this
out right but I think I think I think I
think the battle will be over who can
look like they are the reasonable party
in this dispute James and Katie thanks
for joining me
when you have a medical problem who do
you speak to do you ring up one one one
or do you wait even longer to see your
GP or as a last resort you may opt for a
e but what about the pharmacy I'm joined
by our social media editor Lucy Dunn who
believes it's time to free at the
pharmacy
Lucy thanks for joining me you've
written a fantastic article for this
week's spectator magazine about why we
need to free the pharmacy now this is a
very topical piece I think a lot of
people will be able to relate to it but
I know for you this idea started when
you first moved to London and you had a
medical incident what happened
yeah so um I had a little red patch
appearing on my nose
um and at first I thought it was just a
normal spot over the next couple of days
it began to enlarge it got really itchy
and it developed this Golden Crust which
as I've nearly graduated doctor I can
recognize as being impetigo for that you
need to get an antibiotic cream and so I
didn't have a GP down in London because
I'd literally just moved hadn't had time
to register even
um so then I phoned the pharmacist went
in because I know that from my mind the
pharmacists should be able to prescribe
so I went in and I was quite surprised
to be told that even though my
conditions you know my symptoms matched
exactly what impetigo was it wasn't a
typical at all
um I had to go on phone 111 and then go
into a e and so now I was waiting for
about
I think five to six maybe even longer
hours until I could finally get this
cream for my nose I mean there's so many
frustrating aspects of that story but
let's break it down a little bit
um you are a qualified doctor so you
knew that this wasn't a normal spot as
it started to develop and you also had a
really good sense of what you needed a
lot of people won't be in that situation
uh and once they're turned away from the
pharmacy the prospect of going to a e
will also seem quite extreme I mean it's
it's ridiculous that you had to sit in a
e to essentially get what was a topical
cream in order to address your issue a
lot of people just be turned off
altogether though about seeking out that
treatment and what would have happened
had you had waited to to treat this spot
well that's the thing empathize was a
really infectious condition and so
you're actually told not to go into work
if you've got it because you can pass it
on to other people and which is why I
was referred to you know to to try and
get that cream on the same day
um but it can scar as well you know so
it's it's something that you do need to
get treatment for relatively quickly and
you can eat like the same day
um so it was it was just a kind of
completely went out of control from my
perspective I thought you know why on
Earth can you not get the cream that's
literally a meter behind the pharmacist
on on a shelf
um and yeah it really did get me get me
thinking of it and in your piece you you
go through your own personal frustration
but then you get into some really
interesting
um comparisons between what England is
doing compared to Scotland and compared
to other European countries what are
other countries getting right
so yeah in other countries so in parts
of Europe and in Canada New Zealand and
parts of the US and pharmacists have far
more prescribing power and which means
that they can actually
um use their own qualifications and to
make decisions and give patients
treatment that you otherwise wouldn't be
able to get over the counter and so you
know this is not an unprecedented move
um and and other countries have
obviously brought in measures to ensure
that pharmacists in certain parts can
actually
um take on more of our GP role and which
I think is something that that we really
want to start seeing in the UK given the
state of the Health Service just now
you've done a medical course how much
parallel is there between what someone
training to be a pharmacist goes through
and what a medic goes through yeah I
mean it's actually really similar in
terms of the the grades that you need to
get in to the degree in the first place
and pharmacists are exceptionally bright
but also the length of time that you
study for and most medical degrees are
five years and Pharmacy as well you do
five years and before you're a
pharmacist so
um that was kind of my main frustration
with this whole situation was thinking
well if we can graduate with you know
prescribing Powers we can graduate with
this clinical
um wealth of knowledge and just decision
making and by we you mean Junior doctors
yeah yeah exactly then then surely
pharmacists you know they they surely
should be able to as well one of the um
concerns that people will cite when it
comes to pharmacists being able to
prescribe more medication is that you
don't want people to get too flippant
with the antibiotics prescriptions that
there could always be that rare case
that really someone should have been
referred to a GP and they went to the
pharmacist instead
um how legitimate do you think those
concerns are and what would your
response be to them well yeah absolutely
I mean this is really the main the main
thing is to make sure that pharmacists
also are aware of when to refer upwards
and that's that is you know part of this
whole it's not even changing just
changing sort of a part of a curriculum
it's changing our sort of culture and
attitudes and what you want is a
pharmacists to have that confidence in
themselves to say well I know that I can
prescribe that you know an antibiotic
for a UTI I can prescribe antibiotic for
impetigo
um but if it's something that's more
serious they will also be able to
recognize that too so I think that that
really is massively important and those
concerns are very valid and but that is
something that pharmacists can also
learn as well
with the crisis in the NHS as it exists
now with the 7 million person waiting
list on NHS England Alone
um and and a real difficulty at the
moment to even get access to GPS people
are going to be craving the ability when
it comes to those smaller ailments to be
able to walk in and get something on the
same day and in that in that sense I
think your argument's really going to
resonate but there do seem to be some
political hurdles here and you hint
about that in your piece as well I mean
why isn't this just an obvious yes let's
do it let's free the pharmacy well this
is the thing I think you know there are
um people who think that that wouldn't
be the best way forward so
um there were concerns and study javids
I think had to say that he wanted to
bring in Pharmacy First for England and
we've got a program like that in
Scotland which
um it's quite contrived but it does mean
pharmacists can prescribe
um some antibiotics for certain
conditions better than nothing exactly
um but this was uh not um move forward
thanks to pressures from number 10 and
concerns about this being anti-gp I
think fine you know that there is there
will be GPS that might feel like
pharmacists are kind of stepping on
their toes but equally like GPS need the
help they need people to take those
minor ailments away from them so they
can focus on their own waiting lists and
their own sort of more more
um serious conditions that they're
seeing coming in their doors so
um it you know it's not like there's a
sort of shortage of work for them just
now that's absolutely true one of the
criticisms of uh the way that Healthcare
overall works in the UK under the NHS is
that there isn't a lot of focus on
preventative care and I'm sure that when
you were working as a junior doctor you
saw a lot of people coming in who
probably didn't need to go to a e or at
least wouldn't have needed to go to a e
had they been treated earlier when you
were sitting in a e with this issue on
your nose what were you thinking to
yourself seeing it from the other side
I I mean I actually felt quite
embarrassed actually being there but
given that I was I had such a minor
condition and there were people around
me who many of them looked very visibly
unwell
um but you had no other option at that I
had no other option and it didn't it did
also make me have more sympathy for
people who do turn up to 80 with minor
conditions because people feel that they
don't have anywhere else to go if you
can't you know get in touch with your
general practitioner if you can't get
anything from your pharmacist then you
know to to get better you think well any
is the only other place I can head to so
indeed uh very topical this winter uh
Lucy thanks for joining spectator TV
last week yay formerly known as Kanye
West announced that he was standing for
president in 2024. and he asked Donald
Trump to be his running mate could this
cause a real divide in the Republican
party I'm joined by the spectator's
deputy editor Freddie gray in the studio
and spectator world's Amber Athey joins
us from Washington D.C
Freddie you've written in the magazine
this week that yay formerly known as
Kanye West and his presidential bid
could potentially split votes within the
Republican Party how so and how
realistic is that well I sort of I guess
I muted it as an idea I'm not sure how
realistic it is because of the sheer
craziness of the yay campaign yay 2014
Kanye West 2024 presidential campaign is
so insane and so uh off the wall that
it's hard to know how real it is right
but what is interesting is that yay had
this dinner last week uh with Trump who
Trump and him have been friends for a
while because he's dared to support
Donald Trump in 2016. and a bit more
further on uh and what's interesting is
that he brought along this guy called
Nicholas Fuentes who's sort of totally
toxic to most of the media uh and has
said lots of very shocking things about
women and the Holocaust and Jews and so
on and yet the two of them sat down
Trump and Fuentes sat down together and
apparently got on very well so this has
caused lots of headlines
and has also sort of revealed to me it's
revealed some sort of splits within the
Maga the Trump Coalition uh who were
very disappointed in that speech that he
gave the campaign announcement speech uh
because they felt it was very low energy
it was quite safe it was the speech of a
politician and Trump himself said uh he
felt it was he was too much of a
politician and what they want is the
crazy Trump of 2016 and almost the whole
atmosphere of ye 2024 is a desire to
bring almost Nostalgia for the sort of
craziness of 2016 and this hope that
they can revive that balmy Coalition
albeit with a real sense of over
correcting there have been a lot of
headlines now from some of those
previous Maga supporters uh in the
Republican Party who have condemned
Trump for sitting down with Nick Fuentes
and people that
um on and often occasion have supported
essentially white supremacist views yeah
well I'm going to go out and live and
say I feel a bit sorry for Trump on that
and actually Nick Fuentes feel sorry for
Trump on that because uh he didn't know
who Nick Fuentes was I mean that's
pretty obvious I think uh it was
obviously his security team were
hopeless he Kanye West said I'm rolling
with this guy do you want can he come in
and Trump presumably said yes Amber may
know better than me but Trump presumably
said yes and they just ended up sitting
next to each other and getting on very
well Trump didn't know that Fuentes was
on record as a holocaust today Fuentes
just flattered him and said if only
you're more authentic to your true self
you will win the nomination obviously
Trump loves that because he's an
egomaniac right but I think this idea
that trumps have deliberately sat down
with the Holocaust denier is rubbish
Freda doesn't seem like Trump is
planning to apologize or roll back any
aspects of that dinner anytime soon
which is really the trumpian way but
Amber another person who isn't
apologizing is yay in fact he seems to
be doubling down on those outrageous
anti-semitic remarks you are actually at
an interview very recently where he
walked out after 20 minutes can you tell
us what happened yes I was at the Tim
Pool Studio where they host the timcast
IRL show and uh Kanye or yay rather had
flown into the area that afternoon and
was planning on doing a one to two hour
interview but ended up walking out after
20 minutes and I spoke to Tim Poole
before the interview and he told me that
he really just wanted to talk about the
newsworthy elements of yay's recent
dinner with Trump he wanted to talk out
how it was that Milo yiannopoulos became
his campaign manager how it was that
Nick Fuentes got involved and was
invited to the dinner in the first place
and what the two men actually spoke
about when they sat down with one
another but it was almost immediately
that yay started getting into this idea
that everything bad that's happened to
him is the result of the Jewish people
and their power in society and when Tim
Poole I thought rather respectfully and
lightly pushed back on that yay
threatened twice to leave before
actually doing so and he ended up
leaving in a car with Milo yiannopoulos
and Nick Fuentes just a few minutes
later
um Amber I want to get into the the
details of what's happening with EA's
campaign um and how this is affecting
American politics but you wrote a
fantastic article for spectator World
detailing your experience of being in
the room and then actually being kicked
out of the room by yay and everything
that you saw unfold I mean Freddy's been
speaking to the insanity of this
presidential campaign I think your
article uh really uh gave a sense of
that Insanity too
it was a very weird day I mean look I
got there around 5 p.m and the first
thing that we heard was that the car
that was supposed to pick up the group
of hooligans from the airport had
actually gone to the wrong airport it
was at Washington Dulles instead of the
Frederick municipal airport and these
this Trio chose to kill time by going to
a Hibachi restaurant which
coincidentally uh is right next to the
movie theater where I went to many dates
on in high school that was sort of our
high school movie theater they finally
got to Temple's house and
um it seemed to me that yay was already
in a very bad mood and that this
probably wasn't going to end well
several fans of the show and Friends of
the show were following him around and
asking him for pictures and just
suffocating him so by the time he
actually got up to the studio I'm sure
he was tired from a cross-country flight
annoyed that he had Hibachi girl for
dinner and uh probably also annoyed that
he had this flock of fans following him
around the house so I was supposed to be
in the room for the interview and when I
first got in there he looked at me very
suspiciously and like he didn't want me
to be there and he eventually said that
he basically didn't want anyone in the
room that was not actually sitting at
the table and participating in the
conversation so I was pushed back down
to the basement to watch the show with
all of the other guests
and Amber did you get a sense that it
was the team around him steering the
ship did you think that yay was calling
the shots did you think there was any
coordination or plan when he sat down to
do that podcast
that's a really good question because it
did seem like this was heavily
coordinated by Milo as opposed to yay
Milo is long time friends with Cassandra
Fairbanks who is a former Gateway pundit
writer and is the current Booker for the
timcast IRL show and before the program
Tim Poole was discussing the sort of
flow of events and what topics they were
going to cover with Milo so I don't know
if Milo appropriately relayed all of
that information to yay but Tim Poole
did tell him that if yay brought up
anything related to his anti-semitic
beliefs that he was going to have to
challenge him and then yay brought it up
in the first couple of minutes so it
definitely seemed like this was a
coordinated event from Milo as opposed
to something that EA was really
interested in
Freddie there seemed to be three key
names associated with this presidential
campaign so far yay Nick Fuentes and
Milo yiannopoulos can you tell us a
little bit about those two other
characters yeah I think most people know
Kanye West as a rapper and a fashion
designer and Global icon Etc et cetera
milianopolis is a online provocator a
controversialist i Stanford
himself a while ago but now he's back
with Kanye a lot of people are very
angry about that Nick Fuentes is a much
younger guy uh not ex-gay as as Milo
claims to be he is a quite a radical
nationalist a Christian nationalist a
white nationalist I think he even
accepts that term and he has cult
following because he says very shocking
things about uh gays the Holocaust and
so on
and that makes you uh viral online uh
make of that what you will uh and he's
been de-platformed but he has this kind
of cult status because he's he's seen as
a sort of banned Rebel Freddie this is a
really tough one to cover because on the
one hand uh yay's platform so far and
the particular stances he's taking seem
to be predominantly about promoting
anti-Semitism are there any other pieces
of evidence that he might have some kind
of policy platform and how seriously do
we take this run well I think I think
what binds uh yay Kanye West to Milo and
to Nick Fuentes is on the surface
anti-Semitism I mean that's The Grubby
part they know they can say shocking
things about Jews online it gets lots of
attention and so on but also and I think
they're they're quite sincere in this
and this is not necessarily connected to
the anti-Semitism although you could say
it is that they are very committed
Christians or at least they want to be
seen to be very committed Christians so
yay is very Evangelical about
Christianity he thinks that God is
breaking him down as the way he puts it
to become a perfect vessel of his will
make of that what you will but that's
what he thinks
milianopolis is a convert to Catholic
he's flirted with cultism as far as I
know all his life but he's recently
converted to Catholicism as an ex-gay
he's renounced his homosexuality and
he's embraced traditionist Catholicism
and in that uh podcast that Amber sat in
on or did not sit on I should say uh he
has a rosary next to him Nicholas
Fuentes is also proclaims to be a devout
Catholic so there is this what they're
saying in all their messaging is we're
going to put Christ first we're going to
be explicitly Christian nationalists and
there is a feeling on the right call it
the far right of America that there is
an opportunity for Christian nationalism
now that Trump sort of tapped into but
didn't really because he's obviously not
a very committed Christian so there's a
lot of people that think that's the
opportunity for that for that for that
sort of thing and that's something Kanye
West could tap into the problem is is
that it's a Bonkers campaign uh which is
seems to be sort of slightly ironic
slightly trolling all the time it's not
really serious Fred that's a quite
messed up version of Christianity that
it sounds like yay and Milo and Nick are
promoting Amber what do you make of that
do you think that the Christian right is
really going to be responding well to
this form or this interpretation of
Christianity it seems pretty unlikely
um just because of the toxicity that
they've used to present this message and
I think Freddie hits on an important
point when he says that under different
circumstances there would be an
opportunity for a christian-centric
campaign to do well in America the right
has been pushing back pretty
aggressively on the sexualization and
grooming of children that's been going
on in both schools and in popular
culture valenciaga's campaign fashion
campaign a couple of weeks ago was a
prime example of that and then the
identitarian politics that have taken
over a lot of the left as well as the
critical race Theory that's being taught
in schools and so people on the right
see this and they say this is a cultural
opportunity an opportunity to change the
culture from the right and take a more
social conservative tack that's rooted
in Christianity but when you have these
three Messengers I think it makes me the
entire thing really toxic and it's going
to be difficult for any serious person
to talk about it in a way that is
logical comprehensive reasonable
I think just about it now I think what
what was really interesting to me in
2015 2016 was talking to a lot of
Evangelical Christians who saw Trump as
this sort of imperfect physical this
David figure that would kind of save
America because he would he'd come from
sin and he'd been sort of purified by
his conversion experience to the right
and I think a lot of Americans want to
put that onto a lot of people on the
internet anyway want to put that onto
Kanye West that he isn't similarly he
came from a very decadent Hollywood
world and now he has seen the light he's
had this sort of conversion experience I
think a lot of people want that to
happen but that will happen is not true
and Fred in terms of social
conservatives who are
Lord in the 2024 presidential race in
the Republican primaries anyway there
will be some stiff competition I mean
you've got Ron DeSantis who I don't
think anyone is describing as a liberal
but his brand so far anyway is not um
clouded by this toxicity that both you
and Amber have alluded to when it comes
to very obscene remarks promoting
anti-Semitism well Rhonda senses problem
on the kind of Maga right is that he
doesn't have that Gonzo appeal because
he is a party man he's a republican
first and foremost I think he's socially
conservative enough I don't think he's a
closet neocon as some people are
suggesting uh but he is
um he's a he's a politician he's a
classical politician in many ways and
the appeal of trump was always that he
wasn't that and then Kanye West is an
even crazier version of trump in that
sense Amber what do you make of this
idea that now to embrace the trumpism of
the Republican party or even to appeal
to parts of the Republican party you
have to have this shock factor and is
yay frankly where this was always going
to lead to the idea that you have to
become more shocking you have to say
more aggressive and uglier things in
order to get attention or is this quite
unique to yea as an individual do you
think
I think this is fairly unique
um you know if anything the 2020
presidential election with Trump's loss
setting aside the claims that it was
stolen from him
um was I think
specifically with suburbian voters a
rejection of this shocking personal
aspect of his politics people were
really fatigued by a lot of the non-stop
media coverage and and breaking news
stories that came out of the Trump
Administration and Biden did campaign as
the return to normalcy president
obviously that is not true but that was
the perception of him by a lot of people
and and by the media so I don't think
it's really the case that politics is
just going to continue to get crazier
until the country Falls to Pieces but I
think there's something to be said for a
politician with real natural Charisma
and that's the thing that Rhonda is
perhaps lacking that makes him not as
exciting of a choice for the Maga right
and that's really interesting
um so Fred final question to you how
long do you think we're going to be
witnessing this presidential run on
yay's part if he continues to act the
way that Amber witnessed just getting up
and leaving interviews being scattered
and all over the place and if he
continues to come out with these
offensive remarks how long can it last
well I was a big uh I wouldn't say Mara
but I was very interested in the yay
2020 campaign where he he oh yeah he set
himself up as the founder of the forgot
about that he was head of the birthday
party which I think is one of the best
names for a political party of all time
uh what did that stand for I don't even
remember the birthday party we were just
talking about oh well Criminal Justice
Reform which is what he agreed with
Trump on whether uh Nick Fuentes and yay
agree on Criminal Justice Reform is
another question
um he's a strong pro-lifer
um and it was a sort of it was a sort of
parallel campaign to the Trump campaign
but anyway he spent 12 million dollars
13 million dollars 12 million of which
was his own money apparently
um and he got about 70 000 votes so I
would imagine that
um the 2024 campaign will be similar and
it will just sort of bubble along
spending lots of money occasionally
popping into headlines when he does
something very shocking but basically
everyone will forget about it I don't
think he'll well he may try for the
Republican nomination I don't think
he'll get very far so essentially I
don't think it will exist in any
meaningful way
Freddie and Amber thanks for joining me
and finally a chance to look back at an
old favorite in British television Neil
Clark has written in this week's
magazine about Lolo and its enduring
appeal he joins me now
Neil thanks for joining spectator TV for
the magazine this week you write about
the television show a low a low 40 years
on what is it about the show that has
lived on Through The Years well first of
all good morning Kate I think fans of
the show will recognize that uh greeting
good morning uh well I think the show
really uh is incredible how how enduring
it's been it's as I said it's 40 years
old this month
uh it came out first episode December
1982 and when it came out there were
critics some of the more snooty critics
thought you know is this the sort of
subject matter for a sitcom it was about
if anybody who on this planet hasn't
watched it it's a hilarious farce about
the uh activities of the French
Resistance uh in occupy France during
World War II uh involving the main
character who's a very beleaguered Cafe
owner called Renee
uh he has to be nice to the Germans
because they're the occupying power and
if he isn't nice to them he'll get shot
by the Germans but he has to be nice to
the French Resistance too because if
he's not nice to the French Resistance
they'll shoot him as well and uh and
he's obviously in good true French fast
tradition he's carrying on with his
waitresses uh he's got a wife there as
well so it's all very complicated it's
wonderful fast and it's just
uproariously funny and I think it's
watching it today Kate what's so
refreshing about it is that it's written
by two men created by two men Jeremy
Lloyd and David Croft whose sole Mission
really was to entertain us to make us
laugh what's really refreshing about it
when you can put it against today's
television programs documentary films uh
dramas and comedies so-called comedies
is that the writers don't attempt to
sermonize they just simply want to
entertain us and to make us laugh
whereas today goodness me if you put on
any comedy or drama today the writers
are trying to sermonize to us they're
trying to make political points they're
trying to uh uh put messages out there
a lower low is just funny and isn't it
refreshing to see something like that
today when everything's become too
politicized and everybody who who who
seems to be who want to be a comedy
writer seems to want to sort of use it
to get on a political soapbox
Neil I'm going to put my cards on the
table I am one of those humans on the
planet who has not really watched the
show I mean I've seen some clips but
born and raised in America you can
decide whether or not that's a
legitimate excuse or not
um I can't say that culturally I was
brought up with a show in the way that
many of my colleagues were so really
sell it to me you know when I go home
tonight
um if I'm gonna watch 30 minutes of
television tell me why I should put on
the show from 40 years ago
well I think there's so many good
episodes that obviously they've made
about 90 episodes so there's a few
episodes that aren't quite as funny as
the others but basically it's about
trying to uh get these captured air the
Airmen who who have sort of in occupied
France trying to get them back home to
Britain coming up with all kinds of
schemes to get them back disguise them
in all kinds of outfits and what is what
is I mean it works on so many different
levels because yes it is quite
cartoonish at times and there's nothing
wrong with that what you've got is just
great characters and uh it's interesting
isn't it that the program first came out
the comedy first came out hello in 1982
and it seemed it was more easier to joke
about World War II and take fun of you
know to to make kind of these sort of uh
more serious World War II dramas back
then than it is today it might sound a
bit of a cliche but I don't really don't
think Lolo would be made today uh and
that's an indictment of how we've kind
of lost our sense of humor really uh the
BBC did mute putting out a remake a few
years ago about four years ago but they
dropped it believing it would cause
offense but it doesn't cause offense
it's it's a show that makes fun of
everybody really uh the Italians in the
in the show Italian character Captain
bertorelli is walking on making love
than War as are the French characters
the British characters are silly asses
and uh one of the most hilarious
characters is uh officer Crabtree who's
a British agent who's been parachuted
down to help the resistance and he
speaks the most appalling friend or
rather he speaks uh the most appalling
English in a faux French accent which is
really quite hilarious he talks about
RAF bombing raids and having to give
Michelle the leader of the French
Resistance uh in UV on a massage when he
means a message so there's all double
entendras throughout and you might sell
that to being corny but it's still very
very funny and you've got the classic
fast fast scenes when I mean a running
gag in the series is when Renee is
having a snog with one of his very sexy
waitresses and his wife Edith comes in
and captures them in the act and she
says you know what Rene what are you
doing you know kissing uh you know
Yvette or Millie and he comes up with
these absolutely ludicrous excuses uh
whether it comes from I was trying to
get something out of the back of her
throat she swallowed a bone or something
uh you know when they were on the
snooker table together then he claimed
that they were actually trying to uh
change a light bulb so that that's the
sort of running gag and you have all
these running gags in the series
we know what's coming but it still makes
us laugh and so I think there's nothing
like it there's no comedy I don't think
that's that's like it because it's a
comedy that tells a running story every
episode carries it on from the previous
episode so uh it's it it's not like the
traditional sitcom where each episode is
self-contained and uh there are
misunderstandings there are I mean the
German characters themselves are quite
hilarious we have a very Camp Lieutenant
Gruber who who fancies Renee uh all the
problems Renee's got he's got uh having
to keep these affairs with the
waitresses away from his wife he's also
got a German a German soldier a German
Lieutenant who's in love with him so
it's just wonderful fast fast has never
been done better than by Lloyd and Croft
in Aloha alone
Neil thanks so much for joining
spectator TV thanks very much
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to The Spectators
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode that's everything for
this week thanks again for watching and
do join us again next week
[Music]
thank you
[Music]